[Musique]
l'invité de ce nouveau numéro 2 par 78
c'est un des plus célèbres bouchée de
france hugo desnoyer
pourquoi un boucher dans une émission de
golf est d'abord parce que nous sommes
en période de fêtes
mais surtout parce qu'il a été désigné
comme l'un des ambassadeurs français de
la ryder cup au moment où nous entrons
dans l'année de la ryder cup il est
intéressant de savoir comment se porte
le golf en france
réponse pour l'ensemble des pratiquants
avec olivier denis massé et directeur
délégué de la fédération française de
golf et pour le haut niveau avec
stéphane arbaud de la direction
technique nationale et nous vous
proposerons également quelques idées de
cadeaux pour les golfeurs des cadeaux
qui leur serviront pour s'entraîner
pendant les longs mois d'hiver
et enfin nous terminerons cette émission
par le conseil du pro
[Musique]
vous savez peut-être étonné que je vous
entraîne dans une boucherie pour une
émission consacrée au golf vous serez
peut-être moins quand vous serez que le
boucher qui dans cette mouche qui est un
des plus connus de france c'est hugo
desnoyer et qu'en plus c'est un des
ambassadeurs qui était choisi par les
fédération française de vol
un des ambassadeurs de la ryder cup je
vais le retrouver je suis à nouveau des
loyers dans l'autre nous de godet
driouch et plus célèbre de france
oui c'est bien mais quand même on peut
guérir paris on peut dire de france en
fait oui c'est ça vous être un des plus
saines mouche alors on va parler de
boucherie de votre métier évidemment
parce que nous dire pourquoi vous êtes
vous à tout aussi célèbres ne vous reste
aussi bien des produits et qu'on va
parler de coach parce que vous êtes un
des ambassadeurs
après deux tests
sai qui joue très bien où il va c'est ce
qu'ils disent
j'ai 19,6 de handicap en c'est bien ça
fait treize 13 ans
alors on va parler un peu de votre
métier on dit souvent et hugo desnoyer
la star des bouchers
aujourd'hui ces bêtes à bord et non
parce que vous êtes un des défenseurs et
c'est peut-être pour ça il ya vous êtes
des ambassadeurs de la ryder cup tous
alliés bain des produits de la vérité je
me permette la star des bouchers suis
très content que l'instant à attiches
chez moi ces déviants c'est le gardien
morizet les éleveurs cherchent qu'à
passagers depuis 20 ans chercher et
trouver des prêts mauvais leur écart
avec moi j'ai évolué énormément dans la
façon de les accompagner au niveau de
l'alimentation au niveau des prêts sur
le bien-être animal a débloqué via ces
animaux se tiennent quand j'ai tout de
suite et après je transporte l'abattoir
changer quelques petits détails à
l'abattoir tout ça c'est fait depuis
maintenant c'est important l'aïe un
travail en amont c'est à dire que avant
d'avoir les doutes qui arrive chez vous
vous connaissez les gens qui les élève
césar oui j'ai fait à l'époque la
première ouvert du lundi au samedi
dimanche pour les voitures flashées fait
qu'au début ça a été très facile pour
moi c'est du vivant
et quand c'est son porte-monnaie ben on
va quand vite on apprend vite
oui et puis j'ai eu des parents
aujourd'hui je travaille quel fils des
efforts nécessaires pour que je côtoyais
c'est bien on obtient idées oui c'est ça
il ya une passation de transmission
aussi savoir un vrai débat aujourd'hui
enfin dans la société justement sur la
viande est ce qu'on en mange pas trop
est-ce qu'il vaut mieux pas au manger
bien et tout pour tous de nos jours moi
j'ai toujours été partisan orange et moi
j'ai fait mieux le coin est d'abord la
très bonne qualité
la ville a toujours été un produit cher
où je ne joue pas pour rien mais de tous
les temps ç'a toujours été a produit
vraiment excessivement cher après c'est
une vraie raison est aujourd'hui d'en
manger tous les jours ou ne serait ce
que 5 fois que c'est pas moi c'est lui
moi même j'en mange de 3,4 à pardonner
fois m c'est par cette voie là ça va
après en france on est pas on n'est pas
les gens qui avant des élevages
intensifs ce plutôt les états unis les
choses comme ça oui ça pollue la planète
où il s'est mal élevé où il ya du soja
transgénique où il ya des déforestations
pour justement en planter du soja
ça c'est d'après silva gorille la
quiétude que moi c'est aujourd'hui que
je soulève acté que partage
mettez que je conduis ont réfléchi à ça
c'est demain les uns dont les chinois
vont
une population bien plus élevé ces gens
là va bien falloir les nourrir et puis
d'un produit social et l'argent qu'il
gagne aujourd'hui il doit pouvoir
d'achat bien plus important tim est lui
aussi un endroit ils ont assuré ces
produits là où il n'y a pas de raison
que c'est pas évident c'est pas évident
alors là on est dans le 16e
arrondissement vous avez toujours votre
vous serez dans le 14ème annonce qu'il
distille une petite table doute petit
tableau mais ce que je voulais justement
par rapport au travail qu'on fait que
les éleveurs je voulais que ce soit de
la naissance à l'animal à l'assiette
je trouve ça va super après c'est trop
il ya quinze places c'est pas un grand
truc mais quatre places bien avant c'est
vrai que c'est convivial les gens se
mélangent
il ya des canons qui ferait mais droite
à gauche j'ai beau avoir ça dure c'est
goûter les plats c'est sympa c'est sympa
alors on va parler un petit peu de golf
l'elysée au début de l'entretien
c'est arrivé dans votre vie et une
dizaine d'années un peu plus présent
quand j'ai rencontré votre âme at the
way qui vous a amené oui on a la même
passion qui je le sais bien mon garçon
aussi donc c'est bien là c'est mieux
parce que dans un couple s'il y en a
qu'un qui joue long il a pris du temps
vous êtes un des ambassadeurs de la
ryder cup
ça s'est passé comment vous a demandé
c'est la fédération alors c'est
directeur des communications
on s'est croisé justement une partie de
golf au tournoi de mémoire et
réfléchissante son côté vu déjà les
ambassades qui la veille avait personne
dans la mauvaise c'est vrai que le
service bénévole
parce que là il c'est aussi l'image de
la france qui ce qui se joue c'est faire
du savoir faire français
ça devrait contraire elle fait signer
ces signes sensibles
c'est un rêve limite de gabode qu'il
voulait réaliser que c'est génial à
l'époque les côtes du golfe à la télé tu
rappelles il s était de tele2 antennes
de l économie et à l'époque il retrouve
speitel et les majeures ballesteros
nous sommes des gens comme ça mais à
part le petit écran par ledit écran
devrait côtoyer j'ai toujours rêvé ouais
c'est génial mais non mais être au coeur
de cet événement qu'il était quand même
c'est comme le troisième événement le
plus au gabon mais ce qui m'impressionne
c'est tous les copains maintenant qu'il
s'appelle sherbrooke j'adore qu'on
appelle de partout
vous voyez les autres et je pense qu'il
ya aussi des talents dans un mail à
pendre les jeunes français sont les
circuits
ce challenge tour et tout ça je pense
que ça pourrait donner un bon coup de
boost ça serait bien j'ai absolument un
petit bout puisque on est là on arrive
au fait qu'il est nous qu'est-ce que
vous conseillez vous de votre plat
préféré pour les réveillons je resterai
des shirelles notre culture chrétienne
on va dire moi j'adore la grosse volage
une farce fine de l'intérieur et puis
des cris de tunis mangane arrosée
pendant trois ans et demi trois heures
trois heures et demie moi j'adore la
volaille du pâtis si pascal que sa femme
maria nièce à coulans sur gée à côté de
gallas dans la sarthe coupe du monde
notez les adresses rabat voilà pourquoi
j'ai une des plus belles voix du monde
avec l'oeuvre est réglable et seraient
tous les gens basse et
l'autre couleur papier ça coule à la
bresse des oiseaux 20 voilà j'adore ici
une belle part in pour vous est-ce que
vous alliez à la fois métier et votre
passion pour ses vrais amis que vous
soyez vous donnions des ambassadeurs
parce que leur cible
c'est vraiment d'être quelqu'un qu'il
faut connaître place aujourd'hui merci
beaucoup à vous et bonne foi que
j'enlève énergique
merci
[Musique]
quelle est la situation du golf en
france alors que l'année de la ryder cup
arrive à grands pas on va en parler au
siège de la fédération avec olivier
denis masquer le directeur délégué de la
fédération et stéphane harbour qu'il
responsable du haut niveau
olivier denis massé bouchon vice
directeur délégué de la fédération
chargé de communication de marketing
alors là on est bon dans l'autre de la
fédération nationale travaille sur le
sport de haut niveau le sport amateur et
le sport professionnel tout ça c'est
gérer ici ici alors comment se porte le
golf en france en 2010 est le golf en
france se porte plutôt bien puisque
comme vous savez on est à la veille
d'une grande année pour nous une année
de ryder cup donc on a pu bien entendu
on a anticipé un peu cette grande année
on a
une croissance de nos licenciés donc ce
qui est très bien dans un contexte qui
est assez difficile pour les autres
fédérations et pour nos camarades aussi
des fédérations de golf européenne
donc on est en croissance ça veut dire
que on a les structures pour accueillir
et créer ces nouveaux golfeurs notre
plan de son petites structures arrive
quasiment à son terme un objectif d'en
avoir 100 ans en 2018 on est à 90 est
donc on en serait presque on y sera en
on a plus de 410 mini censier on a des
nouveaux licenciés on a des nouveaux
golfeurs
c'est un peu longuet d'amener au cinéma
américain golf balades visiblement ça
marche mais visiblement ça marche la
billetterie pour la ryder cup grâce à
ses fins ça a été tout est parti en deux
heures on a fait deux vagues
tout est parti en deux heures donc la
billetterie donc il ya un véritable
engouement et plus de place et il s'est
dit je croyais en avoir encore un type
qui vont être remises en vente au
premier trimestre 2010 8 mai c'est assez
c'est assez complet après on a des
opérations de découverte du golfe qui
sont prévues pendant toute l'année 2018
on a un grand ocho qui devrait s'appeler
le ryder cup de golf tour qui est
invisible à visiter toute la france
alors hier à dans les 12 grandes villes
de nos grandes ligues
il y aura une grosse opération et puis
après il ya tous les clubs qui vont
pouvoir s'impliquer aussi bien des
opérations portes ouvertes des
opérations découverte donc l'esprit
c'est vraiment de populariser au maximum
le golf de faire découvrir cette
discipline à travers ce grand événement
un maximum de français et les amener
dans nos clubs et pour que il déprime
découvrent eux mêmes le golfe puis on
finira en apothéose par une super fan
zone sur le parvis de l'hôtel de ville
pendant dix jours à paris la semaine
précédant et pendant la ryder cup avec
retransmission des matchs en direct
animations et tout et puis parce que
c'est bien d'avoir un grand événement
mais faut capitaliser dessus et c'est
l'héritage de ryder cup qui nous
intéresse donc aujourd'hui il est
prolongé après une séquence qu'une
séquence du candidat blood c'est évident
avec les jeux de tokyo puis surtout
paris 2024 sa marque le golf national ça
sera le seul golf quand la durée les
deux au monde qu aura eu la ryder cup
qui a un open du niveau des reliques
series et cora les jeux olympiques
donc on essaie seul parcours au mont
nous rendrait compte si on se replace un
peu dans l'histoire comme ça c'était
assez inattendue pour la france quand
même en été on était assis les autres on
passe à 20 ans on était un petit pays du
golfe on devient un groupe i de golf
on n'a jamais été considéré parce que
nos amis anglo-saxons grise toujours
considéré comme l une des nations
majeures du golfe il manque le grand
champion mais ça nous en parlera demain
qui va nous gagner un grand chelem ou un
tournoi majeur et qui va nous permettre
d'acquérir cette dimension
internationale il peut aujourd'hui on à
750 parcours en france les parcours de
haut niveau on a tout ce qu'il faut en
fait pour on a un événement fin des
évènements de classement elle donc
vraiment tout ce qu'il faut pour devenir
une des nations majeures du golfe on à
la masse de golfeurs tout vraiment tout
ce qu'il faut et la résidence de paris
dans le monde évidemment c'est important
parce avait beaucoup plaidé en fait déjà
dans la candidature d'avoir 7 gilles
paris qui a attiré beaucoup de
de spectateurs et là on se rend compte
que sur les
beaucoup d'américains qui sont mués qui
vont venir pour la ryder cup on a dix
huit mille américains qui ont réservé
leur ticket pour la ryder cup donc c'est
un succès qu un succès mondial et qui va
devrait véritablement donner un coup de
projecteur sur le golf français
alors on a parlé avec vous de
l'organisation et du golfe offense
on va peut-être maintenant parler du
groupe de haut niveau vous deviez il
nous manque peut-être encore le champion
que nous tous les fronts c'est vrai dans
tous les golfeurs français la vraie la
victoire il nous manque une grande loi
parce que tu penses que ledit champions
les arts on a peut-être que je vais
essayer stéphanois on va en parler
l'expérience
merci infiniment merci
version company de stéphane arnoux le
responsable du haut niveau à la
fédération française de golf par les
champions français mais d'abord avec 4
un mot sur le haut niveau amateur parce
qu'il est bon en france ouais il est bon
le haut niveau amateur et bon encore
cette année on est en hébreu d'avoir une
jeune agathe l'aîné 18 ans qui a été
sacrée championne d'europe amateur dame
donc ce qui est ce qu'il vérifie déjà
automatiquement pour le british ladies
open de 2018 donc un majeur féminin donc
un tournoi pro donc ça c'est super super
chose pour elle on a aussi deux guerres
catherine 1
jeune garçon de 18 ans qui a gagné
intention d' afrique du sud avant de
gagner un tournoi pro sur l'app store
qui est la 3e division européenne
cette année donc 18 ans on a aussi
thomas boulanger qui a aussi s'est
illustré cette année qui a 17 ans et qui
a gagné aussi un tournoi pro sur l'app
store qui la troisième division
génération qui monte la jeune génération
donc ce qui est bien c'était plutôt une
année de transition un peu sur les
équipes de france amateur effectivement
cette année aussi titre et championne
d'europe par équipes handigolf par une
équipe de quatre joueurs qui se sont
illustrés cette année en décrochant ce
titre qu'ils cherchaient déjà depuis
quelques années mais ça y est ils ont lu
alors j'ai parlé justement des fans de
golf féminin
traditionnellement il a toujours été
plutôt très bon en france ouais c'est
vrai qu'on a eu des dégradés grande
championne et hélas cette année on peut
noter justement c'est une boutique qui
évoluent sur la deuxième division aux
états unis sur le symétrique qui s'est
illustré cette année par deux victoires
elle termine troisième à l'ordre du
mérite du circuit et ce qui lui permet
de monter sur le sur le circuit pro
féminin 1ère division amériques l'année
prochaine donc loi cela elle va vraiment
découvrir le très très haut niveau
mondial wef féminin et une fois cette
saison finie elle est revenue sur le
circuit européen parce qu'elle veut
également cédant mois sur le circuit
européen et ce qui lui a permis de
gagner son premier tournoi aussi en
chine il ya quelques il ya quelques
semaines sur le circuit du ladies
european tour
j'ai eu la semaine justement où après
une autre française venait de gagner en
inde son premier tournoi donc camille
chevalier que si une euro qui cette
année sur le circuit et qui a gagné
aussi son premier tournoi donc
donc ouais et aussi après ses cocoricos
aussi sur le circuit américain karine
icher qui continuent à terrifier vide en
continu justement son beau parcours
lundi aux etats unis
fini 37e cette année 2 du circuit donc
et ces jeunes qui arrivent derrière
l'équipe aux autres équipes
justement pour aller la chercher alors
pendant des hommes puisque évidemment à
la question je sais pas dix mille ou
cent mille euros que tout le monde se
pose c'est est ce qu'il y aura un
français dans l'équipe de la question
que tout le monde pose encore justement
c'est difficile de savoir de se projeter
mais en tout cas cette année on peut
noter encore voilà une alexander levy
qui elle est qui viennent son quatrième
tournoi dont qu'il gagne c'est un
tournoi cette année ce qui lui fait 4
sur l'european tour
la première victoire de romain wattel
aussi aux pays bas qui courait depuis
mon derrière un retour fracassant de
victor dubuisson reviendra c'est un peu
ça en fin d'année comme
voilà donc ça nous convient quoi on sait
pas ça je sais pas si ça
il aime les fins d'années il est encore
cette année ce qui lui permet d'être là
actuellement 9e sur la liste des joueurs
au classement européen pour la ryder cup
c'est incroyable donc oui on va falloir
compter sur lui en 2018 s'il était
sélectionné ce serait un retour comme on
lui souhaite de connaître sa deuxième
sélection et après aussi des jeunes m
diop avons pas vous le maître du ballon
qu'il ya deux autres étaient sur la
liste ourlets dernière surcharge touré
cette année qui est qui qui qui prouve
qu'il garde sa carte qui a terminé qu'en
9e à la race to dubaï donc ouais ça il
ya confirme sa progression et ensuite
aussi michael lorenzo vera qui les paie
là qui a fait une super saison 6
assiettes des sacs en français plus
gagné un tournoi majeur
ce que tout le monde attend un petit peu
quand même c'est vrai que ça c'est la
question des moyens
ouais on l'a vu dans le passé il y en a
qui sont approchés très froid je la vis
moi je repenserai cas là grégory havret
en citant 2010 les autres on devait de
l'an passé thomas levet aussi donc
donc on leur souhaite en tout cas on
voit il travaille pour la jeune
génération arrive aussi parce que
surcharge tour il ya eu aussi pas mal de
victoires cette année des jeunes qui
monte qui monte sur l'european tour
cette année je consacre mon sort d
adrien stadiers qui va revenir je suis
un guerrier aussi qui revient et des
jeunes qui arrivaient de cette 3e
division là le sourd qui monte sur la
2ème division charge tout ça c'est quand
même un joli signifie un français dans
l'équipe de ryder cup c'est tout le
monde louait tout le monde l'attend il
attend
et puis aussi je pense que ça donnerait
une bonne fée ailleurs que tu perds
derrière en tout cas on souhaite aussi
continuer à travailler comme vous le
faites
merci beaucoup mais dont rien
[Musique]
je vous propose d'ouvrir d'autres c'est
quand un stade aux entraînements et
matériels et pour ça je vais rejoindre
le magasin coop plus rémy eric bonjour
parce que ça arrange bonjour est le
responsable du magasin du boulevard des
airs à paris alors évidemment c'est la
période des fêtes des cadeaux donc on va
parler de cadeau mais c'est aussi divers
beaucoup plus on peut s'entraîner on
pouvait d'ailleurs faire des cadres et
des objets personnellement alors on va
commencer si vous voulez bien par la
balle et les objets pour les avec
lesquels on peut s'entraîner pendant
l'hiver très bien alors j'ai repéré deux
trois choses et puis vous dit à quoi ça
sert il ya par exemple cette plaque là
voilà c'est une plaque qui sert donc à
l'entraînement ou petit n'y a donc
enlevé pour la positionner au sourire
voilà le club vient se mettre comme ceux
ci et vous avez grâce à la plaque est
aussi un miroir
ça permet de voir vraiment où est ce que
vous êtes positionnés si vous êtes bien
vous avez des yeux bien au dessus de la
balle et votre moteur grâce exactement
se voir si vous êtes bien dans la ligne
et si vous restez bien en ligne
justement pour taper la balle bien
perpendiculaire voilà alors il ya un 2e
objet autant bon le matin ils pratiquent
ils auraient pu en douter mais sans et
marquez vainqueur pont je vois pas du
tout alors comme ça vous allez
m'expliquer donc cet outil permet donc
de travailler les sorties de bunker
d'accord et je crois pas ça joue pas sa
main droite voilà donc
suivant l'intensité que vous voulez
donner à votre sortie de bunker
il faut absolument que la tête de club
rentre dans cette cette zone là donc on
peut avoir une sortie de bunker courte
en faisant une petite entrée dans le
sable une sortie de bunker longue on va
reculer le point d'impact dans le bunker
c'est vrai c'est marrant alors rêver
d'un troisième objet je vois pas du tout
en quoi ça peut servir ça ne me sens que
je vais pas leur dire voilà ce petit
bouddha qui
s'appelle donc la barde équilibre
balancepour maintenant effectivement
vous avez deux de marque noire où vous
allez pouvoir positionner vos pieds
alors généralement vous mettez sur
plutôt sur sur les talons comme ça vous
allez vous sentir que le poids est plus
sûre sur l'avant des pieds et ça va
permettre justement de pouvoir
exactement pour l' équilibre donc ça
s'utilise aussi bien à l'entraînement
restait à faire actis avec vos potes au
putting également aussi absolument
et ça va permettre justement de
travailler cette stabilité alors là on a
vu un peu l'entraînement ce que je vous
propose maintenant il ya les villas boas
comme c'est la période des fêtes
il ya des cadeaux il ya notamment
en arrivant de beaucoup de produits
ryder cup au risque parce qu on y arrive
bien ce que c'est bien sûr de septembre
2018 et nous avons un certain nombre
d'accessoires qui ont été lents côté
pour la ryder cup
on va regarder ça ouais
voilà regardez qui va avec eux
ryder cup 2018 donc beaucoup de produits
évidemment on y va menait des petites
peluches et les smartphones avec le logo
ryder cup 2018 que fiat 2018
voilà
alors amis on va finir rapidement avec
eux voilà quelques cadeaux de noël dans
les couleurs de noël de la neige du père
de rouge et du bleu cessera donc on a
des petits des petits sapins avec c'est
très mignon dit voilà le père noël avec
des serviettes et la bla bla exactement
et alors il ya deux mois qui mobilise
beaucoup c'est le breakfast de fait dès
le feu alors c'est une banda regarde et
je vais vous réseau c'est très simple et
voilà c'est très beau sapin ça plaît
beaucoup
donc ça c'est des petits cadeaux
improbable enrouée et et composants sont
très amusants voilà on a vu
l'entraînement les produits ryder cup
les petits cadeaux il ya ce qu'il faut
pour mettre sa part exactement
merci beaucoup rémy civière sicotte
escarmouches
[Musique]
bonjour aujourd'hui dans l'astuce des
champions on a le privilège d'accueillir
la numéro un française karine icher
bonjour quelle réunion patrice braut
mais voilà qu'arrive bien là je suis pas
bien je suis à 40 mètres dans un bunker
je sais pas la faire celle là patrice
c'est un par 5
oui oui bon qu'est ce que tu as essayé
de faire de notre rappeur de l'attraper
en voilà et tu ne pouvais pas attraper
de green non alors le meilleur moyen
dans ce cas là c'est de se laisser un
coup qu'on aime faire est le meilleur
conseil que je peux donner c'est de ces
de jouer un coup pour se laisser en
amont du vainqueur et ne pas se mettre
en jeu parce que la plupart du temps
c'est le coup le plus dur à faire au
golf
donc j'ai choisi de jouer un fer 8 donc
un club beaucoup plus fermé que la
distance normalement je ferai avec un
sandwich par exemple donc les principes
de base d'une sortie de bunker
on ouvre évidemment la face alors
attention ouvrir la phase ne veut pas
dire la ligne et à droite donc il faut
bien faire la différence entre une phase
qui va être orientée à droite et une
phase qui va être ouverte
donc en fait jaffe blimont club comme
ceci donc en fait mon grip est
complètement à droite de mons tence à
partir de là je prends mon stance par
rapport aux grippes
je manque revient dans le sol ensuite
j'ai mais le poids sur la jambe gauche
et j'y reste tout au long du swing très
important pas de transfert de poids et
ensuite c'est parti
fantastique
parfait
facile
[Musique]
merci de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
très vite pour un nouveau numéro de pas
[Musique]